good morning everybody
welcome to the joint audit and standards
committee meeting
i am councillor bryn haron and i am
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meet and
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off i would like to
remind everybody present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet
capable of repeated viewing the whole of
the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
accept exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be informed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of these images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public
and the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
now i'll just make the introductions
mister who is in the meeting today
um we'll be assisted by catherine steele
assistant director for corporate
resources
melissa reverence corporate manager
financial services
and commission and procurement emily
ewell the corporate manager for
democratic services
i'm not sure if sue palmer is here but
rebecca who it
is and that
includes the attendance
now can i move to the agenda please
number one apologies for absence and
substitutions
if we have any mandy morning chair no
there are no apologies or members were
present this morning
oh well done everybody can i have item
two
um decorations of peculiary or
non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare
no it would seem not
item three confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting
of joint order and standards held on the
30th of november
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
councillor matherson please yes um
6.7 um
cifco was consolidated i think rather
than conciliated consolidated
i think that would be
from my memory and what makes sense
yep well spotted john i didn't see that
is everybody happy with that would that
be the correct interpretation
yeah that makes sense yeah that's fine
mandy you're happy with that yes chair
that's good any other points on the
minutes please before i ask for a
proposal and secondary
okay could i have somebody to propose
these please
dave thank you and i can check i can
second them myself
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you
and can i now ask the governance officer
mandy to conduct the electronic vote
when you get there members if you could
open the vote in the modern.gov app
by pressing the plus sign in the top
right hand corner of the agenda
the vote for this item will turn blue
in one moment
if you can click the blue line and
select your voting options thank you
uh
okay we're just waiting for one vote
councillor american would you like to
give your vote verbally
hi yes sorry i think i've got a
user error okay
i seem to be in the wrong meeting okay
how would you like to vote
uh four thank you
chair that's nine votes for and one
abstention
okay thank you very much mandy item four
to receive notification of petitions
have we received any no
none received
item five questions by the public none
received
item six um jac
2010 joint capital investment and
treasury management this is the main
um apologies chair i think item six
maybe questions by councillors
i do beg your pardon i thought i called
that one uh questions
none received no thank you thank you
um agenda item seven joint capital
investment and treasury
management now this is the main um
beef of the meeting today um
i would just point out at this point of
time there has been an additional
paper circulated around just to help
members
but this is um not to form part of the
meeting because it's obviously
um not a public document at the moment
so
rob's computer
and debt portfolio which shows the
position at the 30th of november 2020.
the borrowing for baba is 107 million of
which 95.5 million is pwlb
and 11.5 million short-term borrowing
for mid-suffolk
the borrowing level is 123 million 99
million of which is long-term and 24
million short-term
on the investment side baber has 15.6
million and mid suffolk has 15 million
invested this includes ccla
ubs schroeder's infostec and funding
circle
we have continued the policy of
withdrawing funds from funding circle as
loans drop out and we have not invested
any new money
g shows the treasury management policy
statement
this underpins the strategy and sets out
both councils
regard to the monitoring of risk and
performance and the primary objectives
remains
security of capital and liquidity
followed by
return appendix h is the minimum revenue
provision statement
which shows the basis on how we put
aside resources to repay debt in later
years
there have been no changes to either
appendix g or appendix
h but these are required to be included
within the report to be approved
each financial year appendix i
shows the institutions meeting high
credit ratings criteria
and appendix j is the glossary of terms
and
that's all from me thank you
thank you very much um rebecca that was
a pretty good whistle stop to her
members um i'm mindful of how to deal
with this we have questions i wonder if
it might be prudent and
easier if we um did them in categories
or if i invite um
questions on the first appendix which is
appendix a please
just raise your hand if um you have any
questions
on that i think it'll make for a tidier
meeting if we deal with each
appendage at a time
uh john please yeah thank you chair
yes um i entirely agree with you that
we should look at one appendix at the
time before we get there however i've
got a couple of questions on
on the um the report um
5.1 um talks about links to our joint
corporate plan
and something that's that's been
expressed in various um council meetings
and also
by members of the public is that we
don't seem to
have embedded our declaration of
climate emergency into um
our policies and our working and so on
so i wanted the committee to
consider whether we should ask um
presumably the cabinets initially to
um to actually embed
into the joint corporate plan the
climate emergency
which would then make it easier to um
address some you know those issues
within the various policies and
strategies that we're
discussing for example this morning
5.1 yep thank you um
councillor matheson for that um rebecca
um catherine is this um something you
that you could answer for us
i chair i may actually defer to the to
the monitoring off
versa because uh i think that's possibly
outside the the remit of this committee
but would perhaps just ask the
monitoring officer for her view
emily thank you chairman and good
morning councillors
um first i would suggest that the
cabinet is already
embedding um the climate change pledge
across its corporate strategies and
activities
um however i would agree with the
section 151 in that i don't think it's a
recommendation that can come directly
from this committee in terms of your
terms of reference and your powers
um the comment can obviously be noted in
the minutes
and we can of course make the relevant
cabinet members aware of those comments
but it wouldn't be able to form a direct
recommendation chair
thank you very much thank you it's
reassuring to
hear that the the matter is being
considered already
thank you john yes i'm mindful of this
we've committed to all sorts of things
with the climate emergency um
it's the way we build our houses and
traffic plans but we may pick up the
financial um
things at the end but probably not at
the beginning
it is quite rightly um something that
should be dealt with by cabinet but we
do all
need to keep an eye on it and thank you
for raising that councilor matheson
uh mary mclaren please uh thank you
chair
uh unfortunately i've based all my
questions
on the actual report uh is that a
problem
what what trials and we will see mary i
think let's rather than i did
i mean i read the appendices but in fact
i
it was the report i was sort of
questioning in
various parts is that right yeah we'll
go for it and i'm sure we can um
be quick on our feet okay well page 15
um 4.6 refers to
um councils sort of taking unnecessary
risk
can anybody tell me if if there's
evidence that counts
some councils probably not ours but some
councils have already done that and what
the consequences of that has been
thank you um mary well i think um
nottingham county council have taken a
bit of a hit on something but
catherine yes i
i was just gonna mention thank you chair
there there's a
been a couple in the press recently
about energy energy companies that
councils have run themselves uh
nottingham was certainly one of those
and i believe there was one over in the
west
country as well um there's certainly a
couple of
examples that have been in the in the
press recently
would you advise uh catherine that we
sort of googled that and read it
i believe there has been um certainly a
report from external auditors certainly
on the nottingham one
uh i think it was the robin hood energy
company
um so there is certainly a report out in
the public domain on that one which it
could well be worth
members of the council committee sorry
reading yeah okay thanks catherine the
second question i've got
is 4.7 where we
talk about the grants and support
payments to
residents do we have uh
a definitive figure for that
that's that's a very difficult one uh
councillor mclaren because we've had
so many pots of money that we've been
asked to
to give out on behalf of
the government um i think at the moment
we've got something like
10 business grant funds that we're
we've got opener and are administering
um i
believe on our website there is
quite a helpful diagram in terms of some
of those those grants
at the moment in terms of residence we
are
administering what's called the the
self-isolation
payments program where people if they're
required to self-isolate a low-income
people
then we can pay them up to to pay them
500 pounds
and we also administer money around the
hardship fund for council
tax as well which is more aimed at our
residents so that's
those with support for paying their
council tax but
um i wouldn't like to actually
count up the a number of different
initiatives that we've been asked to
administer on the on behalf of the
government
catherine do you see that though
happening happening at some point
where there will be a collection of i
mean it might be 18 months down the road
but do you see a you know an actual
point where the there is a
an accumulation of all the grants paid
out
i think the different government
departments are doing
some as they go along they do publish
statistics every now and then in terms
of
what different councils have done so i
think it's being done under
programs rather than across all of the
government departments
thank you chairman do you mind if i
could just go through my other
last questions no that would be fine i
think the business grants were 24
million um mary everything else has not
been counted yet
okay um i just need clarification
catherine on the uh page 20
which is the um
replacement refuse freighters can you
just explain to me what that
is yes our refuse freighters
they are i think they have a seven year
life
so every seventh year we obviously go
through a procurement process
and replace the fleet and there are one
or two
that don't happen or at the same time
but
it is a sort of a one-off big
replacement of most of the fleet every
seven years
sorry i saw when it mentioned the fleet
that that was separate to the freighters
i wasn't quite sure on the
the name freighters sort of confused me
but
um on page 21
catherine uh there is um
2.98 million um that is being paid by
baber
is that the 50 investment that we have
with the norse group holdings for the
corks lane
site sorry councilman
can i just uh check where on page
i might need to check with either
rebecca
or melissa on that one but i believe
that is our
contribution to the development the
development of the
site i think that's i was just asking
for clarification for that i thought i
understood that
page 29 uh this is about the pension
deficit oh and i haven't put it i'm
sorry i'm
sorry i haven't put a small a sub number
on that
um the pension deficit for baber was
valued at
uh 19.293 million
six point one catherine sorry chair i
should have thought okay
you're asking all my questions
councillor mclaren oh i'm sorry
don't worry don't worry keep going
um there is in for the baby one there's
a payment
of 0.54 million contribution to that
fund can you explain to me is that a
maximum
or a minimum payment required for that
debt
the 0.54 million is
our baby's annual contribution towards
the deficit
so it's it's the current figure that
we're paying on an
annual basis at the moment that is
decreasing
by one percent of um the employer's
contribution per year based on the last
triennial valuation that we had of the
pension fund
right but so there's no
is there a minimum payment that you
might be required to pay then
we do a combination because obviously
we've got lots of current employees
that we have to make the employers
pension fund contribution
for so that payment happens through the
payroll every month
as we pay pay employees but then there
is the historic deficit
sitting on the fund and we do that as a
lump sum payment
so there are there are two elements to
the pension fund contributions
thank you and you'll be pleased to know
chairman this is my final question
um given the proposed increase
in average weekly rents
is that self-dep defeating
if uh increasing numbers of residents
can't afford their end
and people are unemployed will we be
sort of uh taking
and then putting out in a different sort
of
direction do you understand what i mean
is that
are we defeating the object of
increasing the rents only to be paying
out more benefits to residents
in housing and council tax reductions
yeah thank you i think this is an hr ra
question catherine
but um i'm sure i'm sure you will know
all the answers
as cassettes say i know within i don't
know the exact percentages but i know
within the housing revenue account
um quite a large proportion of the
tenants are in receipt of housing
benefits or universal
credit and they actually go up in line
with inflation
as well so quite a few of those
tenants will see an increase in their
benefits
which will enable them to pay the
increase increase in the rents
obviously is something that does have to
be considered
year on year but equally the
hra having enough income to be able to
manage and maintain
the homes and also be able to replace
them is a consideration so
it's quite a fine balance each year in
terms of that
determination thank you catherine thank
you chair
thank you councilman mclaren um i have
councilor mccrory and councillor
matheson
um councilmember first please your
question
thank you chair i i regret this is less
than a question
and more of something that was just
brought out in um
comment by catherine there um
and i think i'd like to draw attention
to it this is a good opportunity to do
that
catherine mentioned the table of
business grants available to
businesses within baber which can be
found
on our both our websites under the covid
19 and business grants page
it is essential that members know about
this pass the word on and also
the members of the public watching this
meeting now or the next week or so
are aware of it because it's really
handy for those people who've been as
confused as many of us
uh just to have everything in one page
with a summary
even color uh just to make life a little
bit easier
so i just wanted to bring that point up
and ask members to be aware of it and to
publicize it as widely as
possible uh i do beg your indulgence but
i thought it's an important point that
should come out of this meeting thank
you
catherine for raising it yes thank you
for councilman mcgraw there has been
various press releases but it is a bit
confusing so i'm glad to know of that
page
councilor matheson please thank you uh
if i could um first just advise members
of
looking at um council mclaren's question
about risk and so on that the
the various um companies which the two
councils own
either separately or collectively they
do have their own risk registers now and
and these are available possibly not
publicly available but i think available
to members
and um on the pension which
raised i i also had a question about
that
um that it did seem a very small
reduction in the deficit and
it seems to me that the mid-suffolk
deficit would take 33 years to
to eliminate the the rate that's
proposed for the
um the coming year so that that was a
bit um
possibly we should be reducing it faster
than that
so is that a question john you would
like i think it's a question whether
catherine can can
you know say why we're not i seem to
remember we used to be reducing it a
million a year
back in the day the uh
both council's pension funds are
actually in a better funded position
than they
were um i believe the figure that's
quoted
in in the report is the end of march
valuation yes it's just looking at the
report again it's the march 2020
which is obviously a snapshot in time
as i mentioned earlier we do have a
tri-annual
valuation of the pension fund which sets
out the actual
funding level at that point in time i
believe
march 2019 was the last triennial
valuation
and both councils pension funds at that
time
were around about the the 90 percent
funded
so they are improving so we are reducing
that deficit
um and at the payment levels uh we are
making at the moment in terms of the the
half a million that was asked about in
terms of labour and a bit more for
suffolk the anticipation is that all
else being equal
with over the next uh short to medium
term say three to five years
then there's a strong likelihood that
the pension funds would be up at fully
funded basis
so say there are two sort of different
ways there's the snapshot which are the
figures that are mentioned that is just
the
31st of march and that is very much
dependent on the economy at the time and
what
um equities and everything else are
doing at the time
but the triennial valuation is the one
that's the the longer term
outlook for for the pension funds and
what we need to do in terms of our
contributions
yeah so you're saying it's not as bad
not as bad as it looks i mean
and i think perhaps it would be
interesting to see what the
um you know if if the uh if the answer
was
was 90 um kind of 90
of what so are we saying i need to
multiply the
the deficit by 10 to get the aggregate
value of the fund
is that is that what i'm i i would
probably
point you towards the statement of
accounts
where we do a lot more in terms of
disclosures and notes around around the
pension fund
so there's a lot more information in in
that section of the statement of
accounts around
valuations yes
thank you for that chair i've got one
other question on the on the report the
substantive report
um before we actually start looking at
the individual appendices is that all
right
yes yep yeah right 11.1
um i'll just i'll just if you just let
me actually turn to my
as i said i am having a problem with
my the speed with which i can get from
one place to another on here
um i can't even find 11.1 now
oh i mean him to number two sorry if you
just bear with me a moment i do need to
be on the page
that i need to be on i don't think we
have 11.1 in the general report john is
it in one of the opinions
on page 18 yes page 18
thank you very much much obliged just a
moment page 18.
i'm having to scroll all these so it's
just slow work
oh yeah
getting there
ah right
yes oh well this does somewhat similar
to the question i
i asked earlier um i was wanted to
ask what engagement um the
finance staff have had with the members
and the officers of the climate change
task group please
we haven't had representation on the
task group
as such i'm just trying to remember
what's in the
action plan i would probably need to
refresh my memory i know there's a lot
of detail in the climate change action
plan so
i would just need to to go back and
refresh my memory as to whether
whether this is mentioned in there
specifically or not
yeah i think what i was asking was
engagement i wasn't expecting
you know finance to necessarily sit on
the on the group but
but to engage with um what's going on
with
um what i was asking so maybe we can
have an answer to that one
um afterwards then i was gonna say we
certainly are engaged with
um cassandra clements who is obviously
the assistant director with overall
responsibility
um but a lot of the actions i think in
the action plan
cover a wide variety of um
assistant director areas so there will
be engagement through the finance team
with the relevant
finance business partners
write to me afterwards or something to
the committee would be welcome thank you
john are you on that last group yourself
no he's gone he didn't hear that robert
you ever
sorry i was just saying no all right i'm
not
too sure we even know the members yet
but um
well i just wanted to help with chair
with the task group
um i was on the task group but
it's my understanding that the work of
the task this is the cross party
yeah panel but that's finished um
so in a sense it as far as i'm aware
unless
no one's told me that it's still going
on that that it
you know there's not a sort of standing
committee anymore
um so recommendations were made and
and then that's sort of up to everyone
to get on with them i guess
um but um i mean my feeling is we
just because there was some
recommendations made
on the task and finished group is
finished doesn't mean that our
obligation to get to zero is finished
even if all those are implemented it
still wouldn't be enough so
i think we need to keep a kind of
running watch on it
all of us as councillors
okay robert well thank you for banging
the drum on that um i look forward to
seeing the report any more questions on
this substantive paper please all the
dependencies
i've got a few on the appendices chair
but um i was
hoping now that someone else is going to
go next
any other raised hands uh robert
yes sorry i didn't put my camera on
before apologies
um yeah well i'll just go straight to
the one that
sort of bothers me most perhaps um
so appendix c uh
and it's um it's
um 5.19
um and uh
let me get to it
again let's see
yep negative interest rates robert
um further 5.19 further work will be
undertaken
to determine how esg could be
incorporated
etc etc the the second sentence
however whilst the council's current
pooled investments are below the
purchase price
they will not be redeemed at a loss to
invest elsewhere
to meet esg requirements
um i don't think that's the right way to
look at
when we're talking about a kind of mixed
portfolio
[Music]
we're not talking about sort of a single
property or something like that
on the whole esg mixed funds move
in line with the the market you know
where
all sort of mixed funds kind of moved in
line with the market
regardless of whether they're filtered
for um
you know tobacco or fossil fuels
so it makes no difference if you um
divest the part of it and repurchase
because you're
you're buying into you're kind of buying
into the stock market indices
so and this is what we've done with the
the also sit on the
county council pension committee and
we've slowly transferred the
um passive equity part of the fund
into um which was managed by ubs
uh into ubs climate aware fund
we did it in in uh chunks and i think
we've
just about agreed to move the last bit
now it hasn't happened as far as you
know but
um so it's perfectly possible to
to um switch bits of the funds about
when you're when you're talking about
multiple assets and and um
and a spread of investments rather than
a single
stock
and so i do i think i i don't want to be
happy
so again the question is
um well question is can this be amended
please so that
it makes more financial um
sense that you know we ought to i'm not
sure that
can that last sentence be deleted
because i i'm not sure it's um
it's correct
okay that not be a matter for debate
i'm quite happy to withdraw it and and
have it in debate if
if so i wasn't really differentiating
but
especially then
is this something you would like to
advise now catherine um it it
it is a debating it's not really a
question but what is your view
oh we're not hearing katherine
sorry just take myself off mute um i
have sought some advice from our
treasury management advisors
um i can't remember which one of our
investments
our strategic investment funds it is but
i know there is an arm of that that
is more probably on the esg side
but i was advised that you can't just
switch between
the two funds you actually have to
redeem your investment in the one that
you have it
and then reinvest it into another arm
so that does actually mean we would make
a loss
in terms of redeeming it at the moment
because the
current market value is below our
investment price so that's just what the
statement in the report was trying to
say that i as your section 151 officer
wouldn't recommend
we redeem current investments and make a
loss
on them because that obviously then has
less cash
to invest in a different type of
investment
so it's there's not penalties catherine
it's just it's dropped a bit so we would
come out poorer that's what you're
saying isn't it yes
yes yeah it was in the report um
robert i think that'll be a matter for
another day
okay alistair and um then mike please
alistair
uh but just to save time i think chair i
i just like to
say i read that um as just a simple
statement
of a general principle that we would not
be looking at in
most positions to sell at a loss that
that was all i i read from that
and uh i i didn't see any more um
intent than that and i think it was a
quite simple statement and obviously we
could
you could break it down rather more
precisely by looking at the individual
appendix
yeah quite right councillor norris
please
uh thank you mr chairman uh
going back to that last sentence in 5.19
when we mentioned about being a loss are
we talking about
a significant amount i mean a loss could
be anything is
are we talking about millions or are we
talking about
100 000 or what exactly
it does depend on the different funds uh
i know
we had more information in the six-month
treasury management report that came to
the last meeting
of joint order and standards i think
it was the equity fund i can't remember
if that's
the ubs or the schroders one
that was i think the market price was
down by about six or seven hundred
thousand pounds
compared to the investment so it varies
from fund to fund depending on the type
of fund and the market at the point of
the valuation that's taken
but yes we are talking a reasonable sum
of money
thank you yes it certainly sounds a
significant amount
thank you for the answer
thank you mike um councillor matheson
and then councillor
lindsay you have a question to raise
yeah i
i think um i'd i'd be i'm welcome trying
to
do what do you um suggested earlier
chair of actually working at a
questions one appendix at a time and and
i think in terms of the discussion about
appendix c
519 um just now
from councillors i think i think i'd
like to come back to in the debate
um so appendix a um
there's 2.8 um
i i was a little bit puzzled i thought
we could we could use the general fund
to support the
housing revenue account um but not vice
versa
and related to that i'd be
grateful to hear what the
various hra items are in
paragraph 215 and i'll just be looking
for that while i'm
listening get back to that one
2.8 yep i've got up
would you like me to yes catherine yes
it's 20. yeah the
they are separate the hra in the general
fund so you can't subsidize
either way round so general fund can't
subsidise the hra
and the hra can't subsidize the general
fund so they are both
both ring fenced accounts
um was it 2 15
i might have to around the hra i might
have to look to either rebecca or
melissa to see if they have more
information
in terms of the hra
um yes i have
that information to hand
um so was it the specific question was
that the
tables the capital receipts and
what they are
just so this will
2 15.
i think it's the table rebecca on page
22 is that correct
yeah um
just a general question i i thought you
could use the general fund
for capital projects with housing is
that not correct i'm not sure of us what
you're asking john
well that was what i was asking
catherine seemed to be saying no
no you can't but i i was a bit puzzled
at that because i would have thought
the general fund we can do
almost anything with a lot of things
with
you can do housing so you can do like
the um
the companies are doing they are
building houses for market sale
but that is separate from the housing
revenue account
i say the general fund can't be used
to build social housing that's part of
the housing revenue account
but it can more wider housing
oh i well yeah in the sense yeah you
wouldn't want to use the general fund to
to do capital investment probably no i
can see that
okay um yes so the the
yes the 215 the question essentially was
about the um the mid-suffolk lines
in that table uh i was just wondering
what
um what those receipts and and what
those other
amounts were i i couldn't quite think
okay one for one and and other
yep the one for one receipts um
relate to capital receipts that we get
for
the sale of housing properties under
right to buy
and there's an element of those that we
are able to keep to put into replacement
housing um which i believe is
it works out the the extra 70 percent
that normally would have to go back to
central government as part of the
pooling and we have a
a certain time frame on which we have to
spend those on new
new properties um or we have to return
them so
for that reason we are we show those
separately so we can see the element
of those that have kept for that purpose
and then the other capital housing age
gravel seats will be those that
we keep as part of the hra pooling that
don't have to be used for that
that purpose of replacing purchasing new
property or building new property
and that we that we can use for for any
any hra purpose and there's no no time
limit on on
on spending those yeah
i mean it's money coming in
yeah as a result of of doing work on
other properties
no this is um houses being sold
so they are um and as as other than
right to buy
yes yes yes yeah i understand yes that's
the the decision clear right yes the
decision is sometimes
there's decisions sometimes taken for um
houses to be sold
yes yes we see them sometimes yeah
so or that they might need um
a lot of refurbishment work done
make it economic yes
thank you chair that's that's all the
questions that i have on appendix a
unless anybody else has any
mike councillor norris you had your hand
up a while ago or was that an old hand
that was an old hand it should now be
down thank you
that's fine that's fine are there any
other questions
on this paper on any dependencies if you
could just name the dependencies
because we have to we have strayed into
most of them i think we've done most
of appendi's a um yes
appendix b i have quite a number of
questions to understand
more fully if i may okay well we'll
start off with you then john ronna
pendants
thank you um yeah i i know to
the i just have to can someone tell me
what page
i need to get to for appendix b
starts at page 32 32
thank you
ah got it right
right so page 33 3.5
no three point was 3.5 then
ah got it right
3.5 um yeah
i just um wanted to confirm really that
the
um that that what's
stated in in 3.5 will be the case
um the values of properties are
materially below their purchase cost
so we will need an invest an updated
investment strategy
um i think can catherine confirm that is
the case that is needed
i don't believe it is for the investment
properties which is what this
is uh referring to the statement there
obviously says that the underlying
assets do provide
security for that capital investment but
it then says
if that happened then we would need to
update the strategy
but i believe what we're saying is that
those assets do provide
the cover at the moment um so i'll pause
in case i've got that wrong and either
melissa or rebecca wanted to to come in
and make any comment on that
no catherine i think that's correct
that's my understanding as well
yeah thank you rebecca yeah and then on
on 3
10 um i was wondering what had become of
of the mid suffolk having purchased the
two middle school
sites and paddock houses they they
didn't seem to be mentioned
um along here you know in this section
where i would have expected to find them
really
i believe the two middle school sites
have been transferred
to the housing revenue account for
social housing
development that's my my understanding
the two middle school sites have gone to
correct yeah
is well it's also housing proposed
had a house i i'm not 100 sure about
that
that's the same catherine i can convert
that into hra yep
it's not an investment property oh
that's that's very helpful thank you
thank you and um
the other is
418
find that 418
is on page 38
the question was um
what
when did we last receive the um
this this report twice a year to full
council
on the top of my head chair i'm afraid i
i can't remember
time has been passing very quickly over
the last few months so i would need to
go back
but i know um emily attack and the chair
of the sifko board do go along to
the full council meetings every so often
to update on performance but i would
need to to check back on agendas to see
when that last happened
yeah well it's it is quite a specific
statement that it's twice a year so um
i i just perhaps we could actually just
check that
it's actually um happening or going to
get
get back onto that um timetable
quite soon i remember emily attack
i think did she bring the sifko business
plan into council
not that long ago and i think that had
an element of performance
in there as well oh maybe so
maybe so okay good thank you for that
one
and i've got
is it 5.1
up whoops
yes i was struck by the the statement
that
um about
contingency plans and i wondered whether
um they're almost certainly something
that that we wouldn't want to put into
the public domain but i wondered whether
um the opposition groups could see these
on a confidential basis
apologies cancer i'm not quite sure
which part you're referring to
it's the second or the third sets
the third sentence of 5.1 on page 39.
it says that the accounts should
councils
fail to achieve the expected net profit
then both councils have contingency
plans for continuing to provide these
services by reducing overheads
it can etc etc um i just wondered
what these contingency plans actually
were
and what an understanding you might not
want to make them public
that might be a question for emily john
catherine what's your view on this
i i was just going to say that the
contingency plans are what we would do
as part of setting the the budget each
year so if there were
issues that had arisen then through the
debate and the proposals what we would
need to put forward to achieve a
balanced budget position each year
that's that's what would be considered
um the sentence in the report here
is just to give you an idea of the the
sorts of things that would need to be
considered was that the case
just general management i would think
okay
thank you for that are you
[Music]
nearly there yeah i think the others are
debating points chair thank you
um i'll just have a look at appendix c
if no one else wants to look at appendix
b that's all right
i'll just hold the line a minute
emily wants to speak is there something
um due to this part of the debate emily
or even questions yep
the floor is yours thank you sorry i
just had a a problem with my mute
button there it was just in response to
counsellor matheson's previous question
the sifko performance report was last
presented to
full council on the 21st of july 2020
in baby and the 23rd of july in mid
suffolk so
just to confirm that it has has been
within the last
um just about six months good thank you
very much thank you emily just before i
um
call in um councillor casting mccraw
and catherine on 3.9 um
our investment there has gone up is it
because we've done any work or a change
of um
tenant or is it just markup forces on
that one
is the boreham game i believe it is uh
market forces um but again whether
melissa
or rebecca know any more details than
myself on that one
yes i believe those market forces as
well
yeah that's fine i wondered if it was a
result of any work or
change of tenants rebecca but obviously
not that's fine
councillor custon would you like to come
in we're on uh appendix b at the moment
thank you very much mr chairman um just
a bit of um clarification
um on gateway um 14 4.7 it starts there
and it's
talks about suffolk holdings um um owns
100
of the um share capital in a 135
baker site um
further down let me just get to the page
um
in 4.21
on page 39 um it refers to as 150 acre
business park
is there um 15 acres owned by another
um landowner or
i i might be able to try to answer this
one i'm i'm conscious that we did
purchase another part um of gateway 14
we made an initial site purchase and
then i know we added
another piece of land i'm just wondering
if we haven't
actually got the consistency in the
report so
we may have updated one for the
additional
uh land purchase but not the other so
we'll double check that and and correct
it if necessary
okay so it's probably not necessarily uh
it's it's probably in the
the the writing of the report that might
be
yeah okay thank you thank you catherine
um
emily do you want to come in and comment
on that please
apparently not you have a hand raised
emily
sorry chairman that's an old hand i'll
i'll take that down now
oh thank you uh councillor mccraw you
have a raised hands
thank you chair i'll take my hand down
right now save time later
uh just a point of clarification on
page 35 in appendix b uh the point that
councillor matheson made
uh on 3.5 states i i just thought
is this a correct distinction because i
would i be correct in reading that
that's a fair value assessment that
councils
directly owned investment property
portfolio to distinguish it from that
which is indirectly owned
that distinction might be important uh
they are they are two separate
birds as it were one would be contained
within
a vehicle a fund whatever a business a
company
uh the other would be that that those
properties which are directly owned
by the individual councils is that a
correct interpretation
i want point nine cantaloupe uh 3.5
chair on page 35 of appendix b
and it was the point raised by
councillor mathis and i just wanted to
draw the distinction
between those directly owned uh
properties and those that were owned by
one of the vehicles
that the council may have yes i can
confer chair that is a correct
interpretation
thank you thank you valenti
councillor lindsay please and then um
david robert councillor lindsay
you have a hand raised yes thank you
chair
um uh just on
page 43 um
the investment net rate of return
um just really i just it may just be my
complete lack of knowledge but the
[Music]
just a bit of an explanation of these
net rate of returns
what rate of return what's that mean and
what's it net of
and um i'm just trying to understand the
difference between there's a
there's a column for the actual
outcome for for the year go on which is
fair enough
then there's a forecast out turn um
and a budget for 20 oh i see forecast
out to
2021. is that different from
[Music]
that's not budget that's forecast and
then the others
some are budget some are forecast i
don't quite follow why the difference
okay i think charts on page 43
yes yes thank you chair yeah i'll try
and answer those
so in terms of the the net rate of
return
um it's based on the the actual value of
the investment
so it's the the net income that the
council is receiving compared to
that total investment and its uh
net in some cases because for example
for
the cifco investment the council takes
out
borrowing to then lend to
cifco so there is a cost to the council
as well
as the income that it receives back from
the company
so we're talking about the the net so
it's the
the income less the cost that's incurred
is what's meant by the
the net the net return
and then in terms of the the actuals and
the forecasts
uh what you've got here is sort of a six
year picture
and some of that six year is more
certain
than others so of course 1920 has
has been and gone so that's the actual
figure
that we had um the current year of 2021
is our current forecast as to where we
expect
to be at the end of this financial year
we're just in the process of setting the
budget for 21.22
so that column is based on what's being
proposed in terms of the budget setting
for next year
um and then as part of the the code and
producing these strategies we do need to
look for the three years further ahead
but obviously they are forecasts at this
stage rather than having actually been
set as
as budgets and these future three years
they
mirror what is in the um certainly for
the capital programme we show a
projected four-year capital programme
so these indicators tie up with that
that sort of feature look
as to what's being proposed
okay happy for that yeah thank you
investments can go up or down
councillor moeller dave please you wish
yes thank you chair
it's really just a point of
clarification with the point that uh
councillor casten raised
um what is known as gateway 14 was
originally two
sites um the one nearest to the a14 was
known as stone marker east
and the two sites are actually split by
creting road
east so it's possible that um the
the the wording in the paper may be
correct but uh
it was originally two sites before mid
suffolk bought both of those sites for
gateway 14.
thank you chair thank you councilmember
i thought you might have known that
any other questions on the appendices
i've got no hands up appendix c
anybody
no d
any further dependencies right up to i i
believe
counsellors anything you wish
clarification or to ask a question on
now it looks as if we're about to um go
forth into general debate
there's one thing i've sort of read the
paper at length as chairman and
actually i'm slightly concerned i would
think about the level of debt we have as
a council
obviously um we talk about that a lot um
any general comments we're in worrying
times and i do
sometimes feel the ice maybe just
getting a little bit
thin but you're happy and confident with
all this
quite a large proportion of each
council's debt is in relation to that
the housing revenue account
because this report looks across both
general fund and the hra and
you may remember when we entered into
self-financing for the housing revenue
account i think it was back in 2013
we had to take on a certain amount of
debt from the government
to enable us to retain all of the the
rental income
um i know for baber i think the hra debt
is about 85 million pounds
so that's the the largest proportion of
your
or your debt that you've currently got
um yes we have
uh been adding to the debt through
through cifco
um but obviously we've had the business
case for that and
it's scrutinized a lot and reported on a
lot
and generally councils we operate under
the prudential code in terms of
borrowing
so in each case we need to show that we
can
afford and that there is a strong
business case in terms of the reason for
wanting to borrow
and that's the approach that we take for
for the two councils so
looking at individual things in their
own merit and whether they
in essence stack up you know before we
would borrow the money
yes i'm aware of that catherine is the
it's the council house one that worries
me the most
this is the one where we borrowed 80 odd
million to buy back the houses we
thought we owned anyway
a very small point for me and i i did
not support that but um
we are at the mercy of the government
and we were certainly
stitched up i feel on that one it was um
not pleasant councilor matheson you have
one more question
thank you chair yes i have i have just
just found
um i just wanted to confirm on
this is appendix c um 4.7 4.8
the what what this what this is actually
saying is that we will not um
we will not carry out further investment
um
for yield um using other sources
of finance because even using other
sources of finance will preclude
um our use of the public works loan ball
thought for the um for housing
investment
um can catherine confirm i'm clear there
yeah from 21 22 onwards yes that
that is the case so um the capital
programme that's being proposed as part
of the the draft budget will obviously
go into council next
month does not have any debt for yield
in proposed capital expenditure in it
which means that we will be able to
to access the pwlb for the purposes for
which the government intends it to be
there yeah so that that's that's
that's reassuring so we
so we are looking at other sources of
borrowing um
just because they might be um cheaper or
something
yes we always keep an eye out on the
market with our treasury management
advisors because there there are
occasionally
sources that are cheaper than the pwlb
but
when the announcement was made about the
changes to pwlb
lending the government did actually drop
the rate by one percent
on the pwlb so it's become cheaper again
thank you chair uh counselor mccraw was
that an old hand or a new hand
it was a new hand then councillor
matheson made my point thank you very
much
uh well thank you um if there are no
other questions or things for
clarification
um these um recommendations are
up for approval any any other debating
points before we approve them
uh ladies and gentlemen
john a debating point and then robert
and alistair john first
yes the um i think we'll need
um the monitoring officer's view about
um
how far we go um with this i i don't
want to
um quote specifically from the
um the ireland close advisory report on
um esg which is environment social and
governance
matters um but i do
i do think that the um that we should
we should discuss that now and um
so that it is this committee's role
surely to to um
to look at these matters and and provide
our views to cabinet and councils
and um i i must come back to
in particular the the discussion and
questions earlier about
appendix c 519
and where councillor lindsay was making
the view
that there was no um there was no
actual loss in when the whole market was
was was 10 or 20 percent down
in changing from one investment
to another similar investment which
nevertheless excluded
the the um the the unethical categories
of of investment um the only the only
cost
really would be if there was any fees
involved
in in making that transfer but if you um
perhaps something just make the example
then that if you
if you've got a house that you own
um and you bought it for 300 000
and you can now only sell it for 250
but the house that you want to buy has
also gone down
from 300 to 250 then
there isn't actually any penalty to you
because you've still got a house
that you still put the same value upon
um even though you've you've apparently
lost
50 000 pounds and and i think that's a
reasonable parallel
to what we're saying here about 519 that
that we might look as if we're losing
money but really
we're not okay
john i'm not sure it quite works that
way um
councillor castin and then mccraw do you
have points to make in the debate
thank you very much mr chairman oh can
you hear me yes thank you well yes
um yeah 519 yeah i
i wouldn't like to see that um taken out
because some
the um yeah okay the analogy of
two different houses and they're both
from lost value
doesn't really work for me on that
because it's all it's in a
it's in a market that's dropped and
there's some for
example um one of the
one of the investments that we talked
about the most
um the um i can't remember the name at
the moment but um
that's gone up um like 23
since we um since we
last looked at it 30th of september and
it's
it's going about 3 above uk equity
so i'm selling it purely to buy another
investment i i just can't see where
that's getting us because this one's
actually performing well compared with
the other uk equity um
um do funds it's um
i think um yes yes we should sell things
at a loss if they're failing
but when the whole market's down it's
not
you know that um that fund isn't failing
it's it's market its forces on it
which is from a black swan event in the
um
in the market and it's it's really
it's really picking up and it's coming
back so i think that would be
just wasting money to um mess about with
that too much
you're never gonna invest anything
that's gonna give you a huge amount of
interest but
as a whole with the market this these
ones are actually doing well and it's
completely understandable
with the um with the current climate
thank you i'm councillor castle and
councillor mccraw
thank you chair my apologies to the
delay there slightly unresponsive screen
uh a couple of things the esg issues
that have just been referred to
from 5.13 uh onwards
um i i have a very strong feeling that
perhaps we aren't supposed to be
discussing
uh some more detailed papers because
that's not the subject of the paper
we're dealing
with today um it's made clear in the
report
or rather the appendix to the report
that that's an ongoing matter
and and in fact we don't have
conclusions to draw from it although we
obviously we've
been presented with some evidence out of
courtesy
so i'd like to suggest that my feeling
is that that's not something we can
discuss here today
we have a report in front of us um
in the matter of general debate in fact
i mean i i'm thoroughly
i'm pleased to see the end of year
report and this
statement for 2020 to 2021 or
2021 2022 whatever year it is
this one um i think it's report on last
year isn't it
yes uh but i i'm the password
yes it's looking for you in the past
i've actually been concerned as
as other members have about the size of
our debt but it's taken me some time to
realize but eventually i think i've got
my head around this
that although the hra um
and the position of both councils in
building more houses
has seen our large uh long-term debt
provision
rise of course it's also a matter that
we have equally large
long-term returns to finance that debt
uh it's not as though we are doing
anything
if we are talking about 25 years well
that's what we're talking about in terms
of the return
so the figures although they may seem
large
necessarily in order to build houses
they need to be large
so that we can do the job that many of
us feel is one of the principal tasks
of any decently run council uh and i
don't think anybody could argue
against that the provision of social
housing and indeed all housing
is something we should be very much
involved with i'm i'm very happy with
the report i'd be prepared to propose
the report and the recommendations
contained within it um but i'll be happy
to hear
if there's anybody like to second that
and i have no points
particularly to make beyond the its fact
it's an excellently prepared report
um it's consistent with everything we've
received
over the course of each quarter of the
last year and indeed the year before
um so yes uh officers should be
commended for it
thank you councillor mccraw hi
caslamoula are you wishing to second
this paper
yes thank you chair i'm more than happy
to second this paper and i totally agree
with the comments made by
councilman mccraw i think it's an
excellent report and i thank the
officers for
for preparing this report for us today
thank you chair
thank you councilman if i can just
reassure um
uh john councillor matheson um the
things that you're raising
um will go on to the worksheet for the
next meeting and i would think the one
after
they're not forgotten about and they
will be raised and they will be
addressed
but we are where we are on this paper
and um
we're looking back at what we're going
to do i'm not maybe on the way forward
after that
so i would urge a little bit of caution
um
with that and as councillor casten said
it's a difficult market and um
maybe we should wait for a bounce back
before changing
chip chair i did have my hand up for
some time yeah no you
are you are next okay um
yeah i'm not sure i would be happy to um
support this is um
at the moment because i i i'm still not
quite
um confident that with the wording as it
is
on that that 5.19 that will ever
have a situation where the markets
recover enough
so that we can then move to
esg that's it that that statement as it
stands seems to kind of rule it out
unless we've the market recovers to the
sort of
point where we made the purchase
um so
so yeah i um i mean unless i'm gonna
have some reassurance on that
but we're not waiting for some imaginary
time
when the market is recovered back to
where it was because
i think with uh particularly with oil
stocks
they bottomed out they fell to a massive
low about a year ago and although they
bounced back a little they may never
recover
to where they were when we first bought
these investments
so i i are we can i have a reassurance
that we're not ruling out
um a move to sort of
more esg investment investments that
filter out
fossil fuels at some stage in the future
thank you councillor lindsay well you
could put an amendment you could vote
against it
or um we can seek reassurance catherine
are you able to give us reassurance on
the points raised
just in terms of the point fossil field
i think you know there is
a a wide variation of agreement amongst
or views amongst councillors so um i
think what we were just trying to do
with this report
and some of the information that we
shared outside of the meeting is that
this is a complex area
and lots of different areas not just
fossil fuels would need to be
considered as part of that environmental
social and government
governance aspects um so i'm not quite
i'm sure i can give the the reassurance
that uh
councillor lindsey was looking for in
terms of fossil fuels i think you know
it's
it's going to be a a wider and longer
discussion
yes i agree council i think it's going
to be working process
council macro you've got a hand up i
wonder if i could make a suggestion
um as an amendment to the
recommendations to address
councillor lindsay's concerns it is a
discussion we should have
i trust it would happen anyway in our
forward plan
but if the committee was so minded um we
could add a recommendation
and i might be prepared to support it
with a little bit more discussion
for a report on esg to be brought back
to this committee
at some future point i think that would
address councillor lindsay's concerns
and let's be frank about this i think
many of us uh
would have an interest in the in this
approach across the board
whether we would be able to come to any
conclusion after a meeting or two i
don't
know but i think it's worth a try so uh
if my seconder was happy to support
um an additional recommendation
to the effect that a report be brought
back to this committee
perhaps in three months or six months
whatever works best
for the uh schedule of meetings uh would
that satisfy
councillor lindsay and would counselor
mueller be prepared to support that
well first firstly let me just ask
catherine is that possible say
may time um report on the forward plan
to deal with these issues
um i think um the
not the next meeting but the meeting
afterward would be the preferable one uh
obviously we're just coming up to year
end in the finance team so that's going
to take uh uh some capacity and we've
not quite finished the budget process
yet either
so that would be me okay
yes okay if people would be happy
it's after the agm so who knows none of
us may be here but
um uh emily you've got a hand raised
help please
thank you chair just a word on the
construction of the recommendation
the other recommendations within the
report um 3.1 to 3.7 are all
recommendations to council
so you just need to make sure that it's
clear
that this uh extra recommendation is
for the committee it's you're not
recommending to council that you bring a
report back you're
you're setting that um agreement for
yourselves so just to make that clear
chair thank you
yes i think we're just recommending it
to go on the forward plan
for may i would hope um councillor
mueller are you happy with that
yes thank you chair i'm happy with the
proposal made by um
councilman mccraw thank you chair okay
that's good
and councillor matheson and lindsay you
agree that's a good robust way forward
yes i think we've got of course we've
already the report makes reference to a
report we already have from ireland
close
the report before us so we obviously
need something a bit more detailed
with with some concrete proposals
perhaps and options
for what we can do uh as a council
with with our investments so but
otherwise yes i'm happy to
to support that yeah
report was not really before us lindsay
it's just an aid memoir to what we're
going to do in the future
councilor matheson you've got a
handwritten i i i have chair i'd
i wanted to just firstly to say to
councillor cast and he said
why would we sell and the answer is in
support of our
our climate change objectives and
um because of the risk that the the the
non-esg
investments are more likely to go down
which is what councilman lindsey said
had
been successfully handled with with the
county pension fund
as far as the the overall direction of
where we're going with this
um yeah i'm certainly welcome welcome
that
i'm not i'm not sure two months of four
months
four months hence is um quite equates
with with my
um sense of emergency but
welcome nevertheless and i think the
other point that i would want to make
um which is something um that
i would be debating now if we were going
to have that debate now
is is to say that if having having
looked at our various
um pooled investments
the the one that you councillor
lindsay's referred to ubs
which has a parallel
fund which is subject to esg filtering
the currently our understanding is that
the other two main funds investec 91 and
the schroder fund
do not have similar
esg filtered investment funds
and consequently i would ask that
in preparation for for the may meeting
officers investigate what alternative
suitable investments can be found that
do have esg filtering in them apart from
the ubs one that's been identified
thank you thank you councillor masters
and i think that will be part of the
work plan for the future and what we aim
to do
councilman mccraw i just wanted to say
do we need to confirm them with a
wording for this additional
recommendations 3.8
um before we vote upon anything
well we could add that it will be um
hopefully put on the work plan and
hopefully um for a report in
in the may meeting
i'm just adding to the um
or getting ready to add to the
electronic vote
so the wording that i have used if
members are in agreement is
to vote on recommendations 3.1 to 3.7 as
detailed in report jac 2010
and the additional recommendation
to the joint order and standards
committee
that a report on esg investments be
brought to the may meeting
that's that's correct that's exactly
what we're saying and has agreed uh
mandy thank you for that
my point chair is that should it state
the purpose of
that paper uh in that would it be making
recommendations
either to council or to wherever i
believe it probably would be to council
but i believe that for that
recommendation to have any meaning it
does need to be
going somewhere i believe that is to the
intent of
of this meeting i wonder if the word
proposals
um report and proposals um i
think that's what i'd be looking for
i think with all due respect john if it
comes to the main meeting it'd be very
difficult to work up proposals that
quick do you not think everybody
yes that's the point i just want it to
be going somewhere i don't want it to be
a talking shop
if you're going to look at the esp we
need to be looking at it
and um having having a mind a direction
of where it would go
from there that's i think to the point
yes it can have proposals on it but we
would need to um
debate it and talk about it so the
question here is the reporting structure
joint audit and standards in this case i
believe would be reporting to council is
that correct
at a future date mandy and at a future
date so any recommendations we make
however would go to
council or would they go to cabinet
that's what i'm querying i would have
thought they would go to cabin at first
but i need guidance on that
um me too catherine emily i would think
emily chairman i'm happy to to come in
here
um essentially if the committee after
its examination of this
esg paper decides to make um any
recommendations they will be directly
linked to the treasury management
strategy
so much as you're making recommendations
to council today
in the future you would also be making
any recommendations for amendments or
additional elements of the strategy to
council
thank you thank you thank you very much
emily and to chair that just means that
we are actually
being able to effect what we debate and
make recommendations
so yes the question i've is answered we
have somewhere
to go with this i'm happy with that
thank you
councillor macron thank you to emily
that is very clear can you put that in
words um mandy for the committee i'll
come back to you in a moment um
councilmember would you like me to add
um
to the end of that statement um with a
view to
um proposing recommendations to council
i think that covers it i think it
recover adequately thank you
okay john you have a further point to
make yes i just
just wanted to say that i i believe that
the paragraph 519 is he's so
fundamentally mistaken
councillor lindsay and i both tried to
explain why that is
that i i would not be able to support um
the paper um although everything else in
it is
you know it's great work sorry about
that
with this additional recommendation
yeah i like the additional
recommendation if we were voting on in
parts i i'd smoke for that one
it's a shame john for a recommendation
you like you're prepared to vote against
the entire paper but then that must be
your choice
well it's a tough one i can't say why
that can be
councillor matheson because you've got a
recommendation to work on this which is
what you wanted um
you say you cannot support her well 519
may prevent anything from being done as
a result at the moment and that's
we we may have to revisit that at the
same time i suppose
isn't that very much in the hands of
this committee at a subsequent meeting
um that that does that does address your
point and that that's why we're having
that's why we're adding this additional
recommendation i mean i'll be frank
as the proposer that was what my intent
was yeah
all right well so if we can if we can
revise
519 at the same time as as having the
discussion in may well then i'm i'm
i'm i'm more comfortable with it if i'm
still your chair in may and i have no
idea whether i will be john i will be um
i will be driving that forward emily
you've got a hand up emily
thank you chair at the risk of uh
complicating voting matters
um i did just want to point out that um
appendix c
is actually the subject of
recommendation 3.3
um so if the members if members were so
minded you could choose to
um extract that recommendation and vote
on it separately
thereby enabling counselor matheson to
vote against that recommendation but
support the remaining
documents contained within the report
just a potential solution
um for for the situation that's being
described in terms of
councillor matheson's uh support overall
for the for the remnants of the paper
i think having heard what having heard
what the chair has said and so on
um and what's in 519
i i think i can support the paper now
okay so we won't need to have separate
votes
that help everybody i think it could
even make it more complicated john
and um i think we're mindful um both
proposal and secondary and myself as
chair at the moment to drive this
forward so um
it's it's very much up to us john yes
exactly this committee
as to as to how the outcome of 519
and the rest of appendix c actually
comes out it comes about
it's done its job i mean and we're it's
not the report as such that we're really
objecting to or the appendix it's just
it's just the your your concern is the
intent behind it and i think we can
address that through this
additional recommendation right well
said councillor mccrory
and um i'm sure with your assistance we
will not be allowed to go to sleep on
this
councillor norris you have a raised hand
uh
yes say yes thank you mr chairman before
we go into the vote could we
just ask mandy to read out
recommendation 3.8 in its entirety
please
sure yes yes
so the recommendation on the vote reads
to vote on recommendations 3.1
to 3.7 as detailed in report jac
2010 and an additional recommendation to
the joint audit and standards committee
that a report on esg investments be
brought to the may meeting
with a view to proposing recommendations
to council
are you happy with that council thank
you i think that covers it yes thank you
specifically though it's not really a
recommendation to ourselves i mean we
it's a request that this be brought is
it not
i mean it's just a matter of wording but
we can't
we're not we can't recommend to
ourselves because obviously we're going
to agree with that
i think that covers everything to be
honest counsellors
um so we have a proposal and a second uh
if i can ask mandy now to um take us to
the vote and
we will vote on this matter
[Music]
thank you councillors if you'd like to
open the vote in your modern.gov app
by selecting the plus sign in the top
right hand corner of the agenda
the vote for this item should now be
showing in blue
thank you chair all of those have now
been received that's a unanimous vote 10
votes for
right thank you mandy we're still
fighting with that dreadful scroll bar
aren't we
right now we moved to agenda item eight
uh jsc we haven't voted on 3.8
uh we just i think that was
i missed that my page only showed 3.1 to
3.7 and made no
mention of 3.8 oh apologies
i i'm pretty sure i'm right i think
we've only just voted on 3.1
to 3.7
i have amended the vote in in the app
and it should have the additional
wording
it was written there alistair it's all
there
i'm just going to go check back my
apologies i'm just trying to be
absolutely certain
oh and additional recommendation it just
wasn't numbered that's all it was it was
i was looking for the numbers
couldn't see them apologies no that's
okay my apologies
no that's fine mandy that was um spot on
thank you very much
item 8 jac20 stroke 11
forward plan it's on the um agenda sheet
and
are we happy with that we were talking
about this in the
pre-app it was um it's a little bit um
confusing but i think um do you want to
talk us through that catherine
can we have a page number chair would
help me
it's at the very back of your agenda
pack the very best page 77
yep thank you i've got a hard copy so
it's a bit
easier
i was just going to say chair that um i
think there are one or two items on
there that get repeated between
march and may um that we just need to do
some some tidying up and then obviously
get
the annual items on so extend it belong
beyond july as well so and obviously
added the new item which you've just uh
debated on
so we just need to do some tidying up i
think of the forward plan
yeah it was the complete the complaints
monitoring report i think um
yes it was it was the note twice
i thought was a bit odd um catherine but
the constitutional update and the
complaints and monitoring report is
brought to you
or is on every um
okay every meeting and then um obviously
if there is no report it gets removed
then
i thought we agreed it's a running item
okay fine so we've got a very full
meeting on the 29th of
march is that all likely to happen
catherine do you think
we have got a couple of things on there
twice so
um there's the external order interim
update but then we've got the statement
of accounts so
they are in essence one and the same so
that was what i was just saying about
needing to do a little bit of tidying up
and the joint annual audit letter won't
come
i don't believe to that march meeting
because it that comes after you've had
the
report on the accounts so that was more
likely to be the may one
so we just need to do some bit of
changing around
okay and the report we've just been
debated will be part of the may meeting
um
um colleagues so you can be sure of that
okay is everybody um happy with that
don't have to vote on that just agree
that that's um
going to happen i think yes yes that's
correct chair
okay any other questions before we um
call a hold to this meeting
i've got a hand raised from councillor
norris that's an old hand isn't it
yes sorry i'll take it down now yeah
that's fine
uh councillor matheson you've got a
point to me
yes chair the the i i see that mr snell
is with us um and and
i i had just seen i had
wish to ask ask him whether we've
recruited any additional internal audit
staff
that arises from 8.5 of last time's
minutes really
uh right i've seen you in the corner
john is this something you could comment
on
off the cuff we have basically finished
the meeting but i'm sure john
i was some should have got like the
beginning would like an answer are you
there john
he he was there a minute ago yes he's on
my screen
but i'm not sure he's linked into the
meeting is there something you could ask
him out of meeting yeah well i will i
will ask him i think i think it's a
matter of some modest concern to this
committee
uh and i will ask him about it and
perhaps if i get an answer i'll
circulate it
thank you yes or ask um or ask him to do
so to the committee members i think that
would handle it
okay thank you everybody um it's been a
bit of a full-on meeting but we've got
through it all
um thank you to all the officers who are
attending
this meeting is closed at 11 16.
thank you everybody for attending and
your participation
thank you
you